hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn now we're
carrying on but I wanted to review some
of the other things that we had here so
be her hero came to Jessica's aid but he
failed to impress under pressure
Jessica resisted Mike's advances Oh No
well I already knew about that that's
kind of what happened
Mike successfully chased after Jessica I
did oh good so that's good I actually
did that so that means good right
which one will die Chris said that he
would save Ashley oh god what if I did
that and then I lied and James the other
one uh okay Mike hacked off his own
fingers Mike still had a useable machete
so it would have broken if I tried that
okay that's good Mike didn't kick the
wolf good Mike made a friend oh boy
Mike can't do much else but here Mike
Megan friends and finally my got a
jacket and a gun so there's probably
gonna be some method by which I do that
and it seems like this game wants me to
emphasize hiding more than it wants me
to emphasize like actual action and
violence there's something like about
this game that really wants to emphasize
like non-violence balance and everything
wait am I supposed to be doing this
really why would okay fine
bang let's be loud okay worked
let's not check how many bullets we have
left this is continue on blindly because
why not
yeah oh why is it wet here please tell
me that means it's getting warmer
downstairs
I mean I'm obviously following down into
the pit of hell and there's probably
some other secret around here if I don't
immediately go down there hello there
told him or something I did notice on
the totem page that there were a lot of
totems that I was missing along with a
lot of clues so I imagine I haven't been
exploring to 100% of my ability oh look
it is a totem which one is this one
having it bit better Oh death
okay so once again fire bad fire very
bad no do fire no do fire ever dot it so
no fire no fire framily
no fire for this guy no fire anywhere no
fire no fire so long as there is no fire
there will be no trouble so now I can go
back downstairs with confidence
cuz I'm pretty sure I got three death
totems so far let me just check cuz yeah
I was looking at the before I've got
this one well I mean I already found
that one and discovered what was gonna
happen
that was the Bernie boom okay don't do
the Bernie bull is there someone else
there yeah well maybe there was just in
a few of that okay
okay anyway so also wasn't there one
where someone lit on fire yeah that was
the one a lot of people were upset when
I hit the burn and it's like I didn't I
know that I'm like I wasn't supposed to
hit it but at the time I was like what
would happen if I did because I'm
playing this game and it'd be perfectly
honest I'm playing this game the way I
want to play it like I'm sorry if that
makes some people mad but I'm gonna have
fun with this game the way I can and
pretty much this is what it's gonna be
but either way it's really interesting
to see like how much that disturbed
people that won that was not good again
fire pad fire very bad yes oh I knew
that didn't stop it from happening
anyway and that shows that Jess might be
alive so yeah there's a lot of
interesting aspects to this game in this
obviously there's a lot of branching
paths and what I do do I play this game
is I'm gonna play it the best I can
I'm gonna fail in some aspects I'm gonna
succeed another and then it's gonna be
my own personal journey and I appreciate
people telling me that like oh you know
you're doing great are you doing badly
but still in the end of the day
I'm gonna play this game the way I want
to play it I'm gonna have a lot of fun
with it and I'm gonna be my silly self
there's really no other way that I play
games by being stupid and silly and
having great fun with it and that
doesn't mean that I don't take it
seriously either
I take games very seriously and I still
laugh and have fun with them
that's part of the experience I'd be
bored if I just was like stock clip like
this is happening that is locked that is
do rage let me think about that what do
we do
why why why why would I do that no no no
bad bad bad bad I'm not doing it
not doing it cancel cancel cancel how do
I can't sell I didn't want to do that I
didn't want to do that I did not want to
do that I didn't I didn't want to do
that I didn't want to do that oh crap
yeah bad yeah bad I tried to tell you do
to try to sell you I tried to warn you
dude what did I try to do come on okay
so how's much ebooks happen fire bad way
where's mr. saw me and watching from
whoa look at this guy being all cocky Oh
No
hedging it's locked
why who did that recently one crew [ __ ]
going out of here tonight oh man there's
no way I could ever hop this fence bruh
there's there's no way oh man it's like
you possible hey babe how's it going
you ain't flirting with Mike again you
don't know that no yeah you didn't see
maybe we should have checked the shed to
see if it was really true
there's something once you see them you
can never unsee them yes but some things
you have to see for yourself
oh yeah I'll take their word for it on
our friends gruesome murder by the hands
of someone else good acts really wears
an axe is this an axe I don't see
anything oh good an axe but yeah haha
yeah I trust me with an axe hmm how's
worse vicious Matt will break the door
down will ya
whoa wait a second we start smashing
[ __ ] down he's gonna hear us
look you got any better suggestions I
don't know about look what we go that's
great Matt I can just about fit my lip
balm through that little slot come on
you will never fit through there big guy
how dare you how dare you I'm gonna help
you through
I won't fit but you will to that little
hole I've seen you slip into some pretty
tight jeans em hi it's a talent yeah
fine let's do it
she is not a happy camper I mean it's
gonna split us up but maybe it'll be for
the better to go the nonviolent route
for some reason I kind of wanted to
smash the door open I feel like that
might have been better more
time-efficient cuz then she's gonna be
then there all by herself
hover pack off her legs she'll fit in
better you shoulda done more squats
squats for life I can fit through there
I'm right here Emma I can't do anything
but I'm right here okay can you find the
latch anything be careful the spiders
I'm just trying
oh listen to the sound of my voice hey
how's it going
you did it oh boy
hey for you good yeah we did good
hey you only said hey what 180 plus ya
god damn wait what are we looking at
crazy we were here just a few hours ago
this must have just happened [ __ ] Scott
one who forgot to Kris and ash and Josh
got it was the only way back don't say
that
jumpin no no not that good flattered
though not it can't jump out what are we
gonna do oh no either but I'm gonna go
check out this message of murder I know
it's like so busted up what they were
doing oh my god yeah like totally I
wonder what's going on here
is that a clue oh no it's dog put that
back where it is mmm says [ __ ] ass did
a number on this joint I'm really
looking at this radio tower condition
before now ah yes and I'm still keenly
observing this radios out here aren't we
little bit curious about what's up there
mmm could be something's here hears so
am I supposed to go to the radio tower
there's another path behind the cable
car oh I wonder oh I wonder what okay
yeah I know why look I was I was looking
at it the whole time
hey Magellan maybe we should get the
cable car working and take the show on
the road no no I'm not Magellan how dare
you maybe we should not do that maybe
you should follow this instruction area
friendly follow uh-huh they're so
tech-savvy oh man there's so Generation
Y if that is the generation yeah their
high school is okay shut up let's see
can I do anything about this no
apparently not I'm just gonna look at it
real hard
great no keys no cable car oh swear one
great what about the fire tower Oh
probably yeah Matt we got to get to that
radio agree no I completely agree yes
pink that was good right but he's got to
pick up the signal that was probably
good
probably Wow play by the rules
what what rules Thanks what rule number
one Emily is always right rule number
two nothing else am i laughing sounds a
lot like rage there's no reason for it
anyway hold on bud
I probably said it still been mean to
you oh my gosh can I help you here what
do you want a little booty boo hey
that's Mike not me
thank you doing good I believe in you or
whatever I'm just gonna look at myself
for a little bit for some reason why are
we doing this why why why is happening
why is everything cool yeah are you
talking to me here your new friend over
there your new battery-operated friend
oh my god totally yeah I agree
oh my god Todd totally follow you like
and subscribe
woo you alright yeah thanks maybe um you
should go first to protect me maybe
she'd be less clumsy there
I got a Dory matter kiss is on the job
all right
Oh boss uh-huh yeah almost pulse follows
almost yeah wait what are you doing get
back here
I'm coming back for you are you okay how
do you want me to hug you okay never
mind
smooches I'm on my way let me know if
you want me to come back you know I'm
moving nothing don't move a little bit
don't move at all can't we're good for
some reason we're good now only thank
god that's over real holy cannoli
okay I can't be this amazing dialog
going on between the two of the
chemistry is just outrageous it's
astonishing really I can't believe I'm
not already in love on my pants so on oh
no they're not
this is it but if it doesn't we need a
plan
these are good then we can just climb
down hooked up turn
are you serious nah it's not like it's
floating in the sky there might as well
be it's pitch black out uh-huh
you think this psychopath is just gonna
give up and run away no but
maybe we should find a safe spot hole
uh-oh
I thought they might have been a path
over there you mean waiting until dawn
oh yeah exactly who wouldn't expects us
go off on her own I'm pretty sure we
love Sam in the bathtub maybe were a
little bit concerned about that all
alone in the house by herself baby you
know my sneaking suspicion is it's still
Josh's fault
and Josh faked his death he put a dummy
intestines on that yeah the rest of his
body was tucked behind the wall and no
one went back to check ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha maybe or maybe he's dead you never
know wait this is paths off to the left
hang on hello
more death Oh fortune ok good good good
good sounds good good good all good
stuff I'm gonna find out what's the
leftover here before I go to the right
hello anybody over here oh wait what are
you doing wait
whoa was I supposed to come over here
was I supposed to come over here was it
something over my knee is he
wait no whoa wait Oh which way am I
supposed to go I never know it's really
confusing and is that moaning or that
cows are here is that caribou wait I've
seen this it is bad wait yeah what were
you step right Dan cliff yeah yep I know
about this one
hello oh okay non-violence peace and
love you want some of my love I've got
excess love I got a lot of love
oh okay never mind then I guess we're
gonna cliff hang there ha get it cliff
yeah okay
I love the song battle it's great song
she's an intellectual listening to our
classical music oh hi then hope you
enjoyed the show
goodbye hello maybe you should be a
little more observant ladies guys I mean
it's totally okay if you're in here
watching me take a bath yeah yeah what
are you doing
creepy yeah okay
oh she naked
pop not anymore okay so how how is she
gonna be tested in all this I mean to be
honest in the original game wasn't she
one that was not part of the prank so
maybe like I still don't know there's
like oh no oh come on I was no I was
going for the oh there was another one
over there there we go okay good
gosh what do I got here things my
clothes really what happened seriously
ah good I don't know what I'm holding
alright anyway so I don't have any
clothes left cliche [ __ ] number two do
I need to get anything else
wow really do I need to set all this
mood to take a bath really really yeah I
mean you think it's a vacation spot so I
guess it's all understood do I need to
take the phone or anything else okay
let's go on this weird scavenger hunt
with balloons and arrows and everyone
else dying around me goo
Hey very what the hell what's over here
hello anybody ker chunk hello somebody
want to show me something
I'll show them something I'll distract
you hello I mean things that might have
been a little louder than it needed me
but okay
does that mean that it's 2 o'clock 3
o'clock I have no idea
1 o'clock yeah whatever hello anybody hi
anybody at all
Josh is there a totally intact Josh okay
very funny
ha ha look at Sam walking around in a
towel but now I just really want this to
be over
all right uh-huh good no not at all oh
man when I get a hand on that Josh I'm
gonna rip him in two oh I'm really gonna
tearing him oh man oh we didn't saw me
like this
vej he's gonna get am I supposed to hang
out in a towel for the rest of the
weekend I mean I'm not opposed are you
Oh towel it is all right this isn't
weird those paintings are getting more
and more disturbing every time I see him
huh I've already seen this ready for
senior prom I know some crime is that me
okay I'll just follow the arrows we're
trying to freak me out guess what you
succeeded but there's party balloons
there's a bunch of happy fun party
balloons a lot of candles someone knows
my aesthetic that door wasn't open
before Lou hey buddy
okay I'm not controlling it anymore so I
guess we're just gonna do this good move
good move guys I should go get the bat
in the basement and use it hi friend
oh boy someone's gonna be following me
now right oh boy I should get the bad
guys come on I'm
with this I really don't appreciate the
silent treatment here okey-dokey I'm
gonna go get that bat now oh I'm in
theater I'm not in the Boston Mantha hi
looking for me no I don't think you'll
have much luck by looking some that from
you're only going to see what I want you
to see and I have quite a lot to show
you going on open your eyes
I'm looking she's quite beautiful isn't
she a beautiful bathing Buzzard
why do you think she has any idea what
lies ahead do you think these were the
last happy moments of this creatures
life why are you watching Josh I'm going
to give you ten seconds nine down this
let's talk about this ha ha throw us ha
ha boy legs let me lie on the side okay
nobody good
okay damn how can I screw this up ah
jump no point in hiding he obviously
knows I'm in here yeah why would I hide
to be such a terrible idea he'd know I'd
be there pop I love Lily O'Leary I'm low
level ooh yeah Bester Doris modesty here
yeah totally remember that you need to
tell bat bat bat bat bat bat bat bat
right there right there
ah no hide [ __ ] Oh No
get the bad the bad turn your light off
crap oh no harm
who says I'm hiding oh oh oh what the
[ __ ] oh come on
you
come on yeah [ __ ] you bruh
I didn't even move my controller what is
this [ __ ] kidding make no handle Oh
Paul whatever whatever this is yep good
good
somehow that works okay come on come on
yep all right come on I can't believe
that works I still alive how in the
world am I still alive why am I not in a
hurry why am I not still running what is
it going on like seriously I didn't move
the controller it's because I'm over
here I don't know like something's going
on okay
good move good move good move I did I
move that controller come on let's go
let's go we have no time to be confused
we gotta go we gotta go now we gotta go
and we gotta go now somehow we're still
alive ain't gonna let you die you're the
main character I think ah I do god best
to go let's just go I don't want to be
here oh wait that's so good thank you
hey you sir I'm not even sure if hiding
would have done me any better and it got
me the white butterfly proof II so I
guess I'd rather take an active role oh
well done the game seems to be going
very well what to do yes yes good work
exploring this whole severe fear uh I'm
just gonna use this pork bill I didn't
do that you do that your overwhelming
fear of failure you turned it against
these people who you said that's where
we're going to torment has it been worth
maybe I don't know
so am i the dude in the mask okay what
what the hell is that oh come on I
already know this I was just playing
what do I need to do I don't know what
I'm gonna do but it's gonna become it's
gonna be collected see calm calm calm
calm calm calm go golf golf relax I'm
Connor Manning the coursing River
check us out as oh no no no Matt they're
gonna hurt us no no no no no no no I am
moving I am moving I ain't moving I'm
just gonna look at my own face and make
a lot of expressions if there's one
thing - you're like it's a lot of facial
expressions mookee all right watch out
watch out screaming burn come here
a benevolent cannibal cannibal good Oh
caribou go reindeer a good irradiated or
they've all load it
I'm the deer whisperer hover the booby
have a Shuba do we meet women - women -
whoopee whoopee slew wobble ooh I am an
assured in Luzerne happen if a dog isn't
gonna come on shoot its go buddy
ah don't let them stiff me Oh anything
but that oh this is worse than death
okay and we're fine we're fine we did
hit it okay so anyway that's all for
this part here I did good I think I have
no idea if I did good
oh no damn it that doesn't look good at
all I don't know god damn it I have no
idea I god I should have hid the last
move there damn it oh well well maybe I
didn't do so good maybe people are gonna
be bad at me but oh well
that's just what happens so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching I
will get to the rest of these new ones
later hag die
screwed up with the thing in the thing
but either way it is what it is so thank
you again everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video
yeah like your shop